masks have become the hottest item in
town many in search for n95 kn 95 and
kf-94 eight news now reporter sally
jaramillo went in search for these masks
today she's live near d.i and valley
view with more on the places you can
find them and also tells us how
available they are
my photographer and i went all around
the valley and searched for these masks
now we did not find them at places such
as cvs walgreens and target but did find
them at local valley wholesale stores
like this cpap store it's been steadily
increasing day by day
to buy arcane 95 masks scott is a cpap
store respiratory therapist he says they
have been getting multiple calls of
people asking for kn 95 and n95 masks
the good thing about the kian 95s is
that they form more of a seal they're
tighter so they're good at blocking and
filtering contaminants ken eineger is
the owner of jkm medical supplies and
agrees last week we got a hundred
thousand
and they they sold out really quick we
just got some more on friday and we have
some more coming in this wednesday and
while there's been reports of people
having trouble getting these masks both
say they have plenty of them the supply
has been
hit or miss
basically we can get shipments in
batches maybe once per month retailers
message tonight right now as long as you
have a face covering of a decent mask
three-ply 95 n95
from what i'm hearing it's a lot better
than just using a regular cloth mask
there's really no need to panic i mean
the the supply will come and go but the
supply will always come both retailers
tell me you can order them online in
phone or in person but in order to get
the best deal you must order more than
one reporting sally jaramillo live local
now